alma está decorando el hotel en donde
trabaja con floreros llenos de
naturaleza muerta ella necesita llenar
cada florero con un quinto con un quinto
de una bolsa llena de naturaleza muerta
si alma tiene cuatro bolsas cuatro
bolsas de naturaleza muerta cuántos
cuartos del hotel van a tener floreros
llenos de naturaleza muerta ok
esencialmente lo que nosotros tenemos
son cuatro bolsas enteras de naturaleza
muerta y cada una de esas cuatro bolsas
que voy a poner justo aquí las tenemos
que dividir las tenemos que dividir
entre la cantidad total que vamos a
ocupar para un florero que es un quinto
por cada quinto de la bolsa vamos a
llenar el florero entonces a cuatro lo
voy a dividir entre un quinto así que
imagínate que aquí tengo una de estas
bolsas vamos a tomarla y aquí tengo una
de estas bolsas le voy a poner justo por
aquí esta bolsa si te das cuenta ya está
dividida en cinco partes vamos a
contarlas
y una parte un aquí dos partes tres
partes cuatro partes y cinco partes es
decir que si nosotros queremos llenar
los floreros con un quinto de la bolsa
podemos llenar cinco floreros con esta
bolsa llena de naturaleza muerta porque
cada florero tendría una quinta parte
del contenido de esta bolsa ok esto es
lo que pasa si nos fijamos en una de las
bolsas pero si nosotros tenemos a dos
ya esto tengo otra más tres ya esto
tengo otra más a cuatro bolsas entonces
date cuenta que por cada una de ellas
por cada una de ellas va a salir cinco
floreros cinco de este cinco de este
cinco de este y cinco de éste es decir
que en total vamos a tener lo mismo que
cuatro bolsas que cuatro bolsas
multiplicado multiplicado por el
recíproco de un quinto que es cinco
sobre un bueno nosotros sabemos que 5
sobre 1 es exactamente lo mismo esto es
lo mismo que tener 4 este 4x tenemos
cuatro bolsas multiplicado por 5 por 5
que va a ser la cantidad de floreros
totales que van a salir de cada una de
las bolsas y también nosotros sabemos
que 4 por 5 es lo mismo que 20 por lo
tanto podemos decir que 20 son los
floreros que vamos a llenar en total o
dicho de otra manera 20 van a ser los
cuartos de hotel que van a tener florero
llenos de naturaleza muerta porque de
cada bolsa van a salir 5 floreros ahora
esto es un repaso un repaso del vídeo de
división de fracciones porque si te das
cuenta en ese vídeo decíamos que cuando
nosotros tenemos un número entero y lo
dividimos entre una fracción es lo mismo
que tener a ese número entero y
multiplicarlo por el recíproco de esta
fracción y recuerda que el recíproco de
un quinto es pasar el 5 para arriba el 1
para abajo y entonces veíamos que
dividir entre una fracción es
exactamente lo mismo que multiplicar por
su recíproco y bueno en este caso
podemos concluir que tenemos 20 cuartos
de hotel con floreros llenos de
naturaleza muerta